hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new amnesia
custom story Black Forest Castle virgin
- okay I've been looking I've been
hunting it's harder and harder to find
good amnesia custom stories things that
are rated above 9.0 but this one was
definitely highly rated you wake up in
an uninviting room with the foreboding
feeling that something is lingering
outside you recall a dark figure
stalking you the night before no it must
have been your mind playing games with
you
you remember tightly closing and locking
the door before resting but the keys no
longer in the keyhole and the door
appears unlocked who or what could have
gotten through from the other side is
something after you
yes yes sir yes absolutely yes there is
nothing more than yes in that regard so
we are diving in to the depths of a
castle in a black forest from the Black
Forest in Germany I'm assuming I have no
idea but I'm always eating from our nd
it's something it's kind of a mixed
emotion whenever I fire up a meze
because I get this feeling like I really
love amnesia and I love playing it for
then I get that I see that opening menu
and I'm like oh yeah okay hello
okay oh man
I really do love it I love it a lot it's
probably one of my favorite games of all
time vlog of castle exploration October
9 1325 I'm starting to think that
Herbert's encouraging that I explore
this abandoned castle was not much of a
help I must admit that my desire to la
find long-lost artefacts a great value
has gotten the better of me the deeper
I've journeyed into this medieval castle
the more disturbing it has become I can
you glass breaking in the distance as if
knocked off shelves by some phantom
resident I am starting to wonder whether
this place could actually be haunted but
no I've never believed in such childish
things there's no way it must be my fear
merely getting to my head as I try to
sleep in his cold room I have found my
thoughts once more draw to the metal
footsteps I heard stalking me for what
seemed like hours early this morning I
am bound to get into bigger trouble the
further I travel through this maze of a
castle this is crazy I should make my
way for the exit before something truly
grave the Falls me I'm guessing moose
man it's probably moose man
that's a pretty safe bet in all regards
the only one of metal footsteps that I
remember ah
tianbao right fire oh why is it gonna
start up
oh just wind nothing scary it's opening
up very much like the original animation
it's got that same atmosphere going on
it lots oh okay all right
oh all right
this amnesia stories because some
stories getting off to a good start very
subtle things to set the atmosphere I
don't have anything yet
I'm not gonna waste any tinderboxes just
alright diving in deep I'm not afraid of
you I'm not afraid of any of you and
there's obviously something behind their
deep out of their way
I said get well ah there we are
was there something else over there in
the dark corner looks like it and
there's a tinderbox
thank you very much now ah there we go
thank you
ha that's always nice to have and they
started me off with full oil somehow I
don't feel any better turn statues ah ah
not today
anything anything nada
check what are you doing on the desk
it's silly Billy Kate a wine stain the
key yeah not the key B wine stained I
have no idea about that but I don't care
to this door yes but let me first check
down here
no no just a wine room is that all there
is this happen all you caught him he's
your custom story Wow
oh oh oh that didn't help much at all
this look like there were tracks
dragging that I have no idea I don't
know why is this blocked up do I want to
know come on
is it a really a good idea to unblock it
if it was blocked up for a reason ah ha
ha ha ha dusty oh I'm so weary of
closets everything ever since that scare
from the things in the night father-god
right there
holy balls ok guess I'm gonna be in this
closet for a while Oh yep I knew it
that's why I was blocked up to try to
keep me from getting it in hey buddy hey
buddy how's it going friend doh
[Music]
let's go
what another gap
[Music]
oh okay there is he there
yeah hello that's right run away don't
even come near me I don't want anything
to do with you okay is he gone I don't
hear him anymore
Oh what why is he just oh good he's
busting down that door that's so helpful
of him have him hub of him leaving
[Music]
did he leave sound outside does that
lead to the outside is this a trap cuz a
trap isn't it
trap oh hello wait if I go down I'll
never come back up what happens if I go
down
what happen there was another door up
here I kind of want to on double check
anything before I make any permanent
decisions oh that's fantastic
door appears to be wedged shut probably
won't open unless great force is applied
you mean
how about a barrel a barrel to the face
ramming speed Blanc nope nope nope nope
okay alright so I'm guessing that I'm
supposed to go down here and then loop
back around Boop boys are stuck in the
trees here oh all right
this looks uh fun
get that noise crunching the crunching
noise once you're in the dark starts
eating away at your brain so anything in
here any moveable bushes all right back
inside Oh
[Music]
okay all right okay don't look a dead
body that's supper lovely lowdown enum
now down to down home Oh what was that I
heard something
something above behind maybe Oh at the
same time I love amnesia hi
I felt that forget how creepy the game
is but you can't stop me monsters yes
you can but just don't try sanity potion
what is this wait
oh hello crowbar whoa what the hell what
the hell what
I don't like that closet you can ask
right off oh my oh what they are now
something is blocking the keyhole and
now the door is stuck need to find
something to clear it how about the
crowbar what no the key gives off an odd
odor as if it's been around a lot of old
books didn't know that could attach onto
a key but Oh
box don't come in here oh my god I gotta
get up oh I gotta get high on top of
something oh my oh me oh my oh me oh my
oh my oh no oh you oh come on let me
have this thank you you can't see me I'm
in my corner I'm in my corner of
Solitude
okay come here you can't go there
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no oh
come on
nothing in here okay stare into the
corner this is a nice wall this is a
nice wall actually it's weird cuz I kind
of see like a face in this one there's
an eye there's another eye the nose
smile there well thank you thank you
buddy
I guess I could hit over by the dead
body there I'm thinking that at the time
okay
I'm gonna follow you I'm gonna follow
you buddy oh babe oh was he smashing
gallon going back the way I came
he's batching mashing oh yeah because I
couldn't come back the way I did come
therefore I have to go another way they
stare that way at I came actually I am
actually out of time so thank you all so
much for watching let me know what you
think is happening either custom story
it's very very good
it's got like oh the difference we did
good at a great cut some stories and
nuances it's very small but anyway I'm
liking it so far this is gonna be a fun
one I don't know how long but it'll be
fun so thank you all so much for
watching as always I will see you in the
next part bye bye